one thing I found useful was reading
through the SDK documentation thoroughly
as well as doing the sample applications
provided such as hello world and notepad
tutorial they are really helpful they
can be a lot of information which is
overwhelming overwhelming to first-time
developers so reading through the SDK
documentation even though you have an
understanding can be very helpful I'd
also like to point out the apps for
Android project source code is being
provided by Google to help first-time
developers overcome many hurdles they
may encounter or trying to develop for
android as well as having some cool
games on there